have like this platform what would you  do  i would buy and sell something i  actually am interested in really  interested in the mask and stuff like  that no you were you were interested in  the masks because you saw the  opportunity exactly buy and sell  something you're actually interested in  because you knew the answer to the last  part you don't give a [ __ ] about masks  you saw the money opportunity that's  good that's called being an entrepreneur  but if you want a real piece of advice  to build a real [ __ ] platform the  only reason i win is because i really  [ __ ] with wine the reason i win is  because i really [ __ ] with marketing the  reason i win is what i'm selling  everybody now kindness and [ __ ] work  ethic i love that [ __ ]  i love be friends  everybody follows money which has spikes  but then they crash it's like [ __ ]  sugar you will never build a massive  platform unless the thing you do is  [ __ ] love because the money part is a  [ __ ]